turning overseas now president biden's
visit to israel is focusing squarely on
iran as the president tells an israeli
tv channel that he wants to restart
talks to end iran's nuclear program but
if diplomacy fails the president says
military force is quote a last resort ed
o'keefe has made his way to jerusalem
for us he's traveling with the president
ed good morning to you what's on mr
biden's schedule today
well tony good morning we're inside a
ballroom over jerusalem hotel where
president biden is meeting with the
israeli prime minister
they're set to announce plans to work
together to stop iran from building a
nuclear bomb vowing to use all their
national powers available to do so
president biden at the start of his trip
to israel the west bank and saudi arabia
wasted no time pointing the finger at
who's to blame for the u.s withdrawing
from the 2015 iran nuclear deal i think
it was a gigantic mistake for the last
president to get out of the deal
they're closer to a nuclear weapon now
than they were before you uh in the past
said you'll do anything and you say it
again that you'll ensure iran would not
acquire nuclear weapons does that also
mean sir that you would use
uh force against iran is that what that
means if that
the president telling israeli television
he's still committed to restarting
stalled talks with other world powers to
end iran's nuclear ambitions a move that
puts him at odds with israeli officials
who've long opposed the talks former
israeli military intelligence chief amos
yadlin israel's purpose is first to stop
iran from reaching the nuclear bomb and
second to stop iran from entrenchment
around the borders of israel welcome to
israel
our brother joseph
today the president is set to be awarded
israel's highest civilian honor the
president's medal and he'll attend the
opening ceremonies of the mahavia games
often called the jewish olympics and
he'll meet with former israeli prime
minister and current opposition leader
benjamin netanyahu who's running again
for his old job in upcoming elections
coming friday a trip to saudi arabia to
attend a regional conference and meet
with the country's king and
controversial crown prince mohammed bin
salman
meanwhile cbs news has learned the u.s
secret services sent home one of their
home early after being detained by
police for allegedly hitting a woman
while drinking at a bar in jerusalem an
investigation is underway but this is
the third agency employee sent home from
an overseas visit this year
vlad given what president all right ed
o'keefe in jerusalem for us thank you my
friend appreciate it